This is the face of an American environmentalist.
Richard Nixon, former republican President
of the United States.
You see, not that long ago, environmentalism
was a fairly bipartisan issue.
But all that changed.
And it might be because of this guy... and
this guy.
Many remember Nixon for Watergate, but a 2012
survey of top environmental groups named him
the 2nd greenest president in history, only
behind Teddy Roosevelt.
And that’s because it was Nixon who created
the EPA and NOAA.
He passed things like the Clean Water Act,
the Marine Mammal Protection Act, the Endangered
Species Act, the Pesticide Control Act and
extended the Clean Air Act.
But some say this was all a political strategy
in order to compete with a potential 1972
presidential rival, Democratic Senator and
outspoken environmentalist Edmund Muskie.
That’s right, in the early 1970’s the
republican strategy was to try to out-green
the democrats.
The tradition of the environmentalist president
continued up to George H.W. Bush, who not
only ran on environmental promises, he passed
an expanded Clean Air Act Amendment in 1990
and appointed the first conservationist to
lead the EPA.
But as his presidency went on, Bush became
less environmental.
Some think it’s due to the recession in
the early 1990’s, forcing him to put the
economy over the environment.
And then there were these guys.
Challenging Bush for the White House was a
democratic ticket featuring Al Gore, who had
just written a book that would eventually
be turned into the documentary “An Inconvenient
Truth.”
Gore’s environmentalism was seen as a threat
by the right, with Bush going as far as saying
he was “so far out in the environmental
extreme we’ll be up to our necks in owls
and outta work for every American.”
Clinton and Gore argued that environmentalism
isn’t just good for Earth, but would be
good for jobs and touted a “market-based
environmental strategy.”
Protecting the environment was now a split
political issue.
Now, you can’t blame this change entirely
on the 1992 election, there were other factors
before and since that have added to the divide.
But since the early 90’s, the general voting
population and members of congress have grown
farther and farther apart on the environment.
The Democrats fight to enact laws to protect
the environment that they feel will help the
economy in the long run and the Republicans
fight against environmental regulations they
feel are making it harder for companies to
prosper, hurting the present day American
workforce.
Environmentalism was once a bipartisan presidential
stance because it was a bipartisan voter stance.
69% of the voting population was concerned
about air pollution when Nixon signed the
Clean Air Act.
It was a smart political move.
So, until the voting public can agree on how
to move forward with things like global warming,
fossil fuels, and federal land rights, America
probably won’t see the political parties
agree on the environment any time soon.